اشترك
و
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في بداية هذه المشاريع المشتركة في اسطنبول
أ
إنشاء مركز التكوين
الخروج من الموانئ والسلام على السطح
فريق أصلع الشيكات
أيضا دجاج السفن هنا و
لقد نمت الجميلات الأخريات ، أنا سفنك
ضمان سلامة الطرق الملاحية
من العديد من التقنيات والمتابعة منها
يمكنك التداول وقد رأينا ذلك هنا و
[موسيقى]
سورة 34 ومعلومات الراديو الكلبة
هذا ايضا
أعتقد ذلك في هذه العملية
في الواقع في شكل وساطة
روسيا
حول الأسلوب بشكل إيجابي
تواصل في محادثاتنا الأخيرة في اسطنبول
لكن هذا الشيء هو منهج التعليم جدا
كانت النتيجة إيجابية للغاية ، والنتيجة التي سنحصل عليها من هنا
سوف تؤثر إيجابيا على العالم كله.
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
إنها تؤيد مهما كان الأمر ، هذه هي كلمتك
أولئك الذين يريدون المساحة في هذا الفيديو
نحن سوف نشرب
[موسيقى]
هل ستجده؟